bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 18 juin
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro de file echo votre magazine qui
revient sur l'actualité économique
locale je vous propose de commencer tout
de suite en regardant avec moi les
titres de cette édition est dans
l'actualité de cette semaine
l'association réseau entreprendre a
organisé une grande journée pour
célébrer 20 lauréats heavy mois et
créateurs d'entreprise nous y étions
cette semaine nous revenons également
sur l'entretien copé qui s'était lancé
dans la prise de vue par drones l'année
dernière la société originaire de monti
le bretonneux d'école en travaillant
pour l'espace rambouillet et nous fait
découvrir son travail
enfin de vous feront découvrir une
nouvelle façon de faire du sport lancé
par un saint quentinois
c'est le circuit training et c'est
alexandre vialle qui lance la discipline
sur le territoire enfin cette semaine
dans notre entretien nous parlerons
concours et financement avec le concours
sky challenge qui revient cette année
2015 les inscriptions viennent d'ouvrir
pour en parler avec moi en plateau nous
avons deux anciens lauréats
donc ils veulent ten qui est directeur
associé de snacks et mco et benjamin
deux pays fondateurs de centimes et eau
nous recevons également jean-marc
bourges aussi chargé des relations
entreprises à la maison de l'entreprise
bonsoir à vous trois messieurs nous
allons parler donc du concours dans un
instant avant cela je vous propose de
découvrir et moi l'actualité économique
de la semaine
et nous commençons par une bonne note
pour la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l' agence de
notation standard and poor's vient de
confirmer les notes de référence en vue
en tribu en lui attribuant à a+ à long
terme et un à moins pour les court terme
l' agence de notation juste que c'est
notre fête les très fortes performances
budgétaires de la casse qui selon nos
confrères du parisien
standard and poor's a même déclaré que
la casse qui bénéficie d'un pilotage
budgétaire de qualité d'objectifs
budgétaires et d'endettement clair d'une
prospective financière détaillée et
réaliste
mardi réseau entreprendre yvelines le
réseau des chefs d'entreprises qui
accompagnent les nouveaux entrepreneurs
organisé entreprendre en yvelines au
palais des congrès à versailles le
rendez-vous des créateurs repreneurs et
acteurs de la création d'entreprise à
l'occasion de cette journée 20 lauréats
heavy noah était à l'honneur nous y
étions regardez ces images signé william
l
pascal berger l'un des 20 entrepreneurs
mise à l'honneur aujourd'hui le jeune
chef d'entreprise basée à trappes a créé
sa société une plateforme d'échangé
inter entreprises destinées aux sociétés
de conseil et entreprises de services
numériques en 2014
son projet a convaincu réseau
entreprendre yvelines qui l'a financé et
accompagner car toute une étape de
sélection avec le réseau entreprendre
pour aboutir à
la sélection tant que en tant que
lauréat moi ce que j'ai vraiment
apprécié sur le réseau c'est la
pertinence des gens qu'on rencontre
parce que c'est vrai qu'on touche à des
secteurs très différents des
entrepreneurs qui sont chevronnés dans
la plupart qu'ils sont bons conseils les
lauréats présentent tous été
rigoureusement sélectionnés en 2014 ont
plus d'un processus de tutorat par un
chef d'entreprise
ils ont bénéficié de l'accompagnement de
réseau entreprendre et d'un prêt de 15 à
30 mille euros à tous et du noir ils
viennent de secteurs différentes
leur point commun ces innovations mais
pas seulement la première préoccupation
que nous avons c'est la création
d'emplois donc on cherche des porteurs
de projets qui vont créer des
entreprises qui vont créer des emplois
on veut faire des futures pme dans notre
succès et mesurer leur succès à mesure
au nombre d'emplois qui crée un
accompagnement gratuit de deux ans leur
est proposé
le taux de survie des entreprises
accompagnées et de 91% à 3 ans et 84 %
pour cinq ans c'est en forte croissance
par rapport à l'année dernière puisque
on était à 13 est moindre en est à 20 et
que sur 2015 on sera entre 20 et 25
donc sur l'art sur le département des
yvelines on est d'abord le seul
dispositif proposé un accompagnement à
la fois financier à la fois
accompagnement par un chef d'entreprise
et par rapport à d'autres dispositifs le
fait d'arriver avec vingt projets
validés cette année c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt une belle performance en ait pas
de contente depuis sa création le réseau
entreprendre ville compte 66 p lauréate
et plus de 800 emplois sauvegardés dans
les yvelines
le conseil et départementales se bat
pour aller fille l'établissement public
foncier des yvelines les filles
intervient à la demande des
collectivités qui souhaitent engager des
projets de logements et de développement
économiques il a été créé en 2006 le
conseil départemental vient de déposer
une requête de référé suspension au
conseil d'état contre le décret du 12
mai dernier qui dissout l'établissement
public foncier des yvelines mais aussi
ceux des hauts de seine et du val d'oise
au profit d'un seul établissement public
cette dissolution est programmée pour le
31 décembre 2015 pierre bédier président
du conseil départemental des îles on a
déclaré qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas que
la politique foncière soit exclusivement
confiée à cet établissement unique et
dans cette émission vous le savez on
vous parle beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
d'entrepreneuriat de création
entreprise ou de reprise d'entreprise si
ces projets sont attractifs souvent
certaines étapes bloque les ambitions et
parfois la motivation la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
propose des stages pour apprendre le
métier de chef d'entreprise nous sommes
allés cette semaine recueillir quelques
conseils regarder devenir chef
d'entreprise
une idée qui fait son chemin dans la
tête des yvelinois pourtant plus de 10%
des entreprises comme après seulement
une année d'existence
une des raisons de la création du stage
par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles pour les
futurs entrepreneurs
concrètement ils vont aborder les étapes
clés donc les fondamentaux qui vont leur
permettre de travailler sur leur projet
de le consolider ou éventuellement de
prendre une décision de passer à la
phase création ou pas donc il ya des
thématiques clés il ya des choses
importantes à savoir par exemple le
statut juridique des statuts juridiques
30 par rapport à mon activité à ma
situation personnelle et ainsi de suite
donc voilà il ya quand même une
réflexion de base à avoir avant de
consolider de prendre la décision de
créer une formation de 250 euros sur 5
jours qui peut être prise en charge dans
le cadre du droit à la formation animés
par des chefs d'entreprise le but est de
partager son expérience tirer un trait
sur les idées reçues et revenir sur les
étapes clés de la création d'entreprise
en général l'étude de marché leur parler
que leur paraît quelque chose
d'accessoires est une formalité c'est
pas du tout une formalité c'est un
préalable à tout le reste
faire une étude de marché fouillez faire
une étude du marché sur lequel on compte
s'installer c'est quelque chose de
primordial parce que c'est de là que
tout va dépendre de la va dépendre la
communication qui vont organiser
de là va dépendre les moyens commerciaux
qui mettront en place de la va dépendre
aussi leur rentabilité et la manière
dont ils pourront assurer la pérennité
développement de l'entreprise
cette future potentielle entrepreneurs
se sont laissés tenter par l'expérience
alors après trois jours nous sommes
allés demander leur verdict aux
principaux intéressés
5 je reviens pas celle d'entreprises ça
c'est sûr 75 mois voire plus mais en
cinq jours ça permet de voir les sujets
qu'on va devoir approfondir vraiment et
c'est ça qui est intéressant et puis ça
permet aussi de voir d'autres gens de
confronter nos expériences
c'est un bon démarrage maintenant 75
genre qu'on va créer son entreprise
c'est ce qu'il nous dit mais il ne
décourage pas c'est ça qui est bien si
en ile de france le taux de création
d'entreprises a baissé de 0 4% entre
2014 2015 dans les yvelines
l' agence pour la création de l'emploi a
noté une hausse de 3 3% par rapport à
l'année dernière
nous allons parler maintenant concours
et six lancements avec l'entretien de la
semaine cet autre site
et nous sommes en plateau avec mes trois
invités pour parler du concours ski
challenge
alors donc à ma droite nous avons iftn
et benjamins du pays qui avait été
lauréat de vous avez des lauréats de ce
concours est un magot jean marc denjean
de si vous faites partie de la maison de
remplissent donc de l'organisation
donc tout d'abord jean marc bouche dira
t il un petit peu voilà le concours
comment ça se passe comment il faut
faire pour s'inscrire il a trente mille
euros à se partager une maison
il est tout à fait le losc ayant trempé
challenge était un concours consacré
dédié aux créateurs d'entreprise mais
aussi toute entreprise installée sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
avec cette année une dizaine de
partenaires et une dotation globale de
30000 euros à partager entre les
différents lauréats très bien qu est ce
qu'on parle de votre expérience
également comment ça s'est passé un
petit peu ce concours pour vous comment
avait déjà eu l'idée de participer à
gerland les hits
alors va pour moi tout d'abord c'était
le premier concours donc c'était un peu
une grande découverte est en fête dont
j'ai eu l'idée d'y participer tout
simplement parce que étant une
entreprise de montigny-le-bretonneux
c'est vrai que l'on regarde un petit peu
ce qui ce qui se fait autour et comme on
était accompagné par la vision de
l'entreprise en fait pour nous c'est
vrai que l'on s'est porté assez
naturellement vers vers ce concours là
et justement les démarches est ce que ça
prend du temps parce que c'est difficile
à faire
alors un concours ça prend toujours du
temps parce que quand on quand on monte
sa boîte il faut déjà essayé de la
comprendre soi-même
alors l'expliqué à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est encore moins évident et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui sait sur un
dossier qui à remplir qui est qui est
assez assez exhaustif qu'on doit ensuite
aller soutenir donc c'est une démarche
qui effectivement est assez chronophage
mais je pense que c'est bien parce que
ça permet en fait d'avoir un jury qui
comprend vraiment ce qu'on fait et qui
nous juste du coup sûr sur la réalité du
projet il invoqua vous présentez qu'est
ce que vous pensez vous le projet
comment il a il a marché pour vous si
vous êtes peut-être distingué dans ce
concours
vous avez quelle catégorie d'ailleurs
moi j'ai participé la concours création
d'entreprise et danger était lauréat
pour le prix coup de coeur du jury
ce qui a fait la différence je ne sais
pas pour elle demandé au jury
moi ce que j'ai trouvé très intéressant
dans ce concours s'est éteint on parle
toujours du de la remise de prix on
parle toujours du résultat mais ce que
vient de dire benjamin est tout à fait
vrai et c'est presque ça l'a le plus du
concours
c'est le fait de présenter notre
capacité de présenter notre projet à des
gens qui ne connaissent pas à un public
de professionnels et c'est déjà une
première validation finalement est un
encouragement très fort de dire voici
déjà ce panel de professionnels nous a
sélectionné nous a retenus
ça nous donne confiance nous donne aussi
un gage de reconnaissance finalement un
vis-à-vis des parties prenantes que sont
les collectivités qui sont aussi les la
partie financière les banques et du coup
c'est d'abord ça la victoire et le
trophée après évidemment il ya le côté
coup de projecteur il ya les dotations
qui se rajoute à ça mais cette première
partie on la néglige un peu et c'est
quand même le nerf de la guerre
être en capacité de présenter en une
minute trois minutes cinq minutes
le projet c'est un exercice extrêmement
difficile on le vit au quotidien
et finalement c'est ce premier exercice
là que maison de l'entreprise nous offre
finalement avec cet accompagnement c'est
cette trame aussi que mme hamida c'est
aussi un petit pense-bête pour bien
faire mais le dossier donc cet
accompagnement d'un nouveau l'entreprise
dessert sur la dotation et c'est un
élément non négligeable c'est presque
l'élément premier qui nous fait arriver
au concours mais finalement ce n'est pas
ça le plus important
c'est un bon exercice dans pour se
vendre c'est comme ça pour peut-être
détecter les talents du territoire oui
tout à fait c'est on va dire c'est un
des outils aujourd'hui qui est mise à
disposition sur la communauté
d'agglomération pour éviter rythmant
détecter les futures pépites nos
startups du territoire ils sont tous les
encourager dans leur initiative au
quotidien sur l'entrepreneuriat le
concours a aussi un objectif de
récompenser voilà le talent
qui anime tous les jours ces
entrepreneurs travailler avec leurs
clients leurs fournisseurs leurs
partenaires créent de l'emploi au niveau
local donc oui c'est un outil
complémentaire qui nous permet de
détecter des talents du territoire de
saint quentin nouvelle avoir trente
mille euros à ses parents plus à
retiration catégorie en quatre
catégories une première catégorie
créateurs d'entreprises bien évidemment
une catégorie commerçants artisans
entreprises de services
il nous semble important de valoriser
aussi l'économie dite résidentiel une
catégorie innovation donc une start up
sur l'aujourd'hui aussi mise en lumière
à travers ce concours est une catégorie
nouvelle catégorie qui est entrepreneur
étudiant notamment un dispositif qui
permet aux élèves du premier cycle qui
souhaitent entreprendre ou qu'ils
entreprennent d'être aussi valoriser à
travers ce concours et des partenaires
notamment via lui verse plus et l'estac
à l'école de commerce qui va bientôt que
la clause d'ingénieurs excuse moi qui va
bientôt s'installer à pied vous cette
source de financement vous y avez pensé
c'était évident talent à un concours 7
c'est quelque chose auquel les
entrepreneurs les gens te ra ne pense
peut-être pas forcément
alors c'est vrai que le concours finance
en général effectivement un petit peu
mais on n'a jamais la certitude de le
gagner en amont et ça prend en général
beaucoup de temps donc je pense que
finalement l'aspect financier pas
forcément toujours l'aspect le plus
intéressant en revanche qui est
extraordinaire c'est que ça vous
beaucoup de porte en fait sur le
territoire sur lequel on passe le
concours et quand on a son siège social
à saint quentin en yvelines c'est avec
participent à ce concours là ça peut
ouvrir beaucoup de portes et je sais que
enfin moi dans mon cas ça m'a notamment
permis de commencer à mettre des
premières machines dans le centre
commercial et ça a vraiment permis
finalement de faire un peu de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines note notre
laboratoire le territoire ont testé les
les nouveaux endroits pour mettre des
machines et nous ça nous a du coup
apporté une crédité locale importante
mais surtout des premiers marchés
testent et ça c'était extraordinaire
et c'est finalement presque ce qui a
plus de valeur pour un entrepreneur que
les que les milliers d'euros qu'on peut
on peut y arriver on crache pas tuer
employeurs parce que un jour donc c'est
sûr que le père qui est beaucoup plus
jeune et ça a été le même la même
expérience pour vous vous tourner
facilement vers ce concours peut-être
que c'est pas une solution doucement sur
non c'est vrai que c'était la première
fois aussi que comme je crois que
que je participer à un concours grenay
oui oui bah pour les mêmes raisons que
benjamin c'est que finalement ça donne
ce coup de projecteur ou aussi et ce
coup de projecteur avec le aussi tout
l'accompagnement après le concours de la
maison d'entreprise permet aussi d'avoir
ses contacts à voir ce réseau et d'avoir
pareil les mêmes marchés testent aussi
évidemment ça crée du lien
enfin c'est certes le concours se faire
qu'au coup de projecteur mais ça crée du
lien dans la communauté d'agglo et du
coup les gens en sont très propices
aussi à nous d'ouvrir les portes à nous
écouter et finalement à nos propres un
peu sous leur aile et ça aussi c'est un
élément très important je rejoins d'un
jean noir parfaitement là dessus on
partage la même expérience dont je vous
encourageais à tous les entrepreneurs à
se penser à faire le concours
moi je pense en tout cas on est sur un
territoire hyper dynamique on a un
énorme centre commercial universités à
une maison d'entreprises capables de
mettre un petit peu tout ça en musique
est un concours qui permettent de se
mettre en avant
finalement et de pouvoir se lancer par
les acteurs donc oui moi évidemment je
pense que quand on a une idée de boîtes
à 50 ans divine c'est ça paraîtrait
contre intuitif de pas se présenter au
concours c'est qu'au-delà des concours
c'est le concours et la maison de
l'entreprise et ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai découvert après finalement je
suis arrivé un peu tardivement auprès de
la maison de l'entreprise j'avais déjà
avancé mon projet c'est eux qui vont
avoir attrapé finalement en disant que
tu peux mieux le réorienter et finance
et tout cet accompagnement derrière et
on en parlait avant de rentrer sur le
plateau de tout à l'heure en disant qu'
on pourrait réfléchir aussi à faire un
partenariat en fait avec les lauréats de
fin du concours de cette année est de
parrainer qu'on puisse nous paraît mais
aussi les lauréats de cette année
pur jus devoir avancer un peu cette
transmission flambeau et ça je trouve
que c'est aussi des vraies valeurs de
saint-quentin de la maison entreprises
et pas de l'entrepreneuriat qu'on
partage le marché est ce que vous auriez
un dernier conseil avant de se quitter à
donner aux gens qui vont vouloir
s'inscrire aux roncquois
oui tout à fait toute façon il faut pas
hésiter à une sollicité au sein de la
maison de l'entreprise on est là aussi
pour accompagner sur les deux dossiers
au montage on a déjà des premiers
retours du fait de l'ouverture de lundi
où les gens nous sollicitent pour pour
les aider les accompagner sur ses
démarches évidemment
principal conseil c'est soyez vous même
quand vous quand vous êtes en face de
votre dossier
ça permet aux entrepreneurs créateurs
d'entreprise de aussi de dresser une
image à l'instant t de leur projet et
aussi de bénéficier de conseils d'un
réseau d'experts qui leur permettra de
mieux affiner soit leur création est
aussi la croissance de leur activité
eh bien ça sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup je rappelle que le concours est
gratuit se dérouleront du 15 juin 2000
15 au 18 septembre 2015
le retrait des dossiers pourra se faire
à la maison de l'entreprise ou sur le
site internet www.skype.com et les
résultats devraient être communiqués au
tour du 1er novembre je vous propose de
continuer notre émission maintenant avec
le chiffre de la semaine 12 % c'est la
part que représente le département dans
les exportations francilienne les
yvelines représente 2,1 pour cent des
exportations nationales sachez qu'en
les importations des entreprises ont
atteint plus de 16 milliards d'euros les
exportations presque deux fois moins
avec plus de 8 milliards d'euros tout de
même
celui pour cent des éco-entreprises
françaises se sont positionnés à
l'export je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre partie magazine avec
l'entrepreneur de la semaine
et cette semaine nous intéressons à un
entrepreneur saint quentinois qui vient
de commencer son activité juste au mois
d'avril il se met donc au service de
votre forme il vous propose de faire du
sport
alexandre vialle et éducateur sportif il
lance son activité de circuit training
qui développe sur tout le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines un nouveau
mode une nouvelle façon de pratiquer le
sport qui se développe
regardez ces reportages réalisés par la
rédaction romain respini pour le montage
2 un pan se portait déjà deux heures
d'exercices et ils ne sont toujours pas
fatigué ces sportifs dominicaux très
motivés se sont donné rendez vous à 9
heures ce dimanche pour s'adonner au
circuit training au parc des sources de
la bièvre à saint quentin en yvelines
alexandre vialle coach sportif est à
l'initiative de ces cours son activité
en fait qui consiste à faire plein de
petits ateliers sportifs donc par
séquences donc vous travaillez 20
secondes 30 secondes sur des ateliers et
vous variez les ateliers en variante
donc les exercices et en mettant pas ou
très peu de temps de récupération
ça permet travailler sur le côté la
musculation et de cardio
la tendance du sport et du bien-être
revient en force surtout avant l'été un
engouement qui a inspiré alexandre coach
sportif éducateurs attrape auto
entrepreneur il a décidé de se lancer un
nouveau défi vous faire faire du sport
en plein air le week-end d'une façon
différente
un service qui change des coachs
personnels ou des salles de sport moi je
le pratique depuis un petit moment
j'ai fait pas mal de concerts obstacles
choses comme ça donc le circuit training
c'était une activité qui était bien en
parallèle pour pouvoir travailler ce
genre de course et on a la chance en
fait sur 50 en avoir une nouvelle un bon
milieu naturel une belle richesse au
niveau de l'environnement donc comme je
m'entraînais un peu partout shdm et
s'ils disent ça serait sympa aussi le
faire découvrir aux gens plus facile je
rapproche les pieds d'accord je descends
bien en bas âge remonte et si je veux
que ça soit plus dur challenge les gens
son entreprise il l'a appelé à l'excès
vous ouvert à tous les niveaux alexandre
entraînent chaque week-end une dizaine
de personnes depuis le mois d'avril
ils viennent de tout le département et
chausse avec plaisir leurs baskets le
samedi ou le dimanche matin chacun pour
différentes raisons
du côté plein air bcge le grand atout
vent fait d'avec ses vous puisque en
réalité - les sports en salle j'ai
horreur de ça
je supporte pas d'être enfermé dans un
endroit dans une salle de sport là on
est on est dans un cadre qui est
extraordinaire en fête en plein air donc
c'est quand même très très agréable
c'est indispensable en termes de
simplement de bien être vraiment parce
que au fur et à mesure mais on rentre
dans la vie active
on se rend compte qu'on rende ta ont
fait plus de sport on n'est plus très
actif on a un peu mou et à bas on perd
son punch on perd même sa vitalité son
envie de rire etc
on a toujours envie de rire mais on est
moins joviale alors que là on reprenant
le sport mais tout de suite tout va mais
si c'est un coach sportif c'est parce
qu'il a les diplômes il à la formation
donc j'ai une garantie de ne pas prendre
le rythme de risque avec ma santé selon
un institut régional départemental des
sports
63 % des franciliens entre 25 et 54 ans
ont une activité sportive pratiquer
plusieurs sports en est à la mode comme
le crossfit cette discipline qui mélange
fitness musculation course et
gymnastique avec alexandre les exigences
aux moindres il s'adresse plus à
monsieur tout le monde qu athlète en
recherche de performance il a lui-même
élaborer les entraînements ça fait dix
ans que je suis éducateur sportif je
suis rentré dans le monde du travail
l'âge de 19 ans j'avais un peu de
douleur de médecine puis comme la
passion depuis toujours c'est le sport
donc je me suis focalisé dessus j'ai
passé tous les concours et diplômes et
puis ça fait déjà un moment que je suis
ici en tant qu'éducateur sportif 10
euros la séance pour ses clients c'est
en moyenne dix fois moins qu'une séance
de coaching personnalisé avec une
moyenne de 200 euros par week-end son
activité ne lui prend que quelques
heures par semaine en plus des vidéos
qu'il propose sur son site internet
mais pour l'instant il préfère garder
son emploi d'éducateur sportif à trappes
pour l'instant je me fixe pas
spécialement d'objectifs mon objectif
principal c'était de mettre le pied
dedans de monter cette activité de le
faire partager aux personnes après sur
le long terme je n'ai pas spécialement
je me suis pas spécialement fixé
d'objectif jeu voir un peu comment ça
répond déjà sur sur le fait que si
l'activité prend celle et les gens sont
intéressés et après on verra en
formation les possibilités restent
grandes dans le secteur du sport moins
de 10 % des français sont inscrits dans
une salle de fitness et ils sont en
france près de 4000 coach sportif
déclaré le marché du coaching
professionnel en france
est estimé à environ 105 millions
d'euros et nous restons en pleine nature
avec l'entreprise de la semaine vous la
connaissez c'est tout de suite
rappelez-vous en janvier dernier nous
vous avions présenté une entreprise ni
montaigne canopée elle sortait son
premier drone roulant le cam quad et
venait de lancer son activité avec des
prises de vues avec cette nouvelle la
technologie donc des drones
nous sommes allés prendre de ses
nouvelles et assister à un de ses
tournages à l'espace rambouillet
williams elle pour les images romain
respini au montage
avez vous déjà vu l'espace rambouillet
sous cet angle la forêt vue du ciel à
plusieurs centaines de mètres du sol
des images inédites pour les réaliser le
parc a fait appel à l'entreprise in
intel canopée une façon de promouvoir le
site naturel avant l'été l'idée c'est de
mettre le visiteur au coeur de ces
petits films d'avoir du mouvement dedans
donc de susciter au regard de donner une
image des émotions qu'on pourra vivre
je veux faire une rotation autour de
l'arbre là je veux plus je veux faire
des plans autour de cet arbre trois mois
de tournage ont été nécessaires à
edouard jany et son équipe pour réaliser
ses films sur le parc
la fauconnerie et les grands animaux
visible dans la forêt 3 - finalement
c'est assez court sachant que c'est pas
trois mois plan ces trois mois avec une
journée de tournage de journée de
tournage par semaine et puis souvent
mené de pandev qui se prévoit la veille
qu'est ce que la météo est bonne et
qu'il faut qu'on en profite peu de temps
pour couvrir les 250 hectares du site
dans les yvelines il existe plusieurs
parcs de ce type alors il faut se
démarquer et communiqué cent mille
visiteurs visitent chaque année l'espace
rambouillet qui espère attirer de
nouveaux curieux pour ce tournage
commandé par halloween f canopée à
utiliser plusieurs drones ainsi que sont
calmes quad une technologie qui a
convaincu le parc naturel du coup je
pense que pour mettre en valeur des
sites comme les nôtres ici c'est un
outil qui est vraiment géniale qui peut
se comparer anciennement hélicoptère
mais heureusement avec des coûts qui
sont pas ceux des hélicoptères quoi si
ça avait été une option hélicoptère je
pouvais même pas pranger à discussion
plus de deux secondes c'est pas dans nos
moyens et dans le budget donc c'est une
manière vraiment de démocratiser ce type
d'image environ 1200 euros la location
d'un drone pour la journée contre 2500
euros de l'heure pour un hélicoptère
la différence de prix est de taille
pourtant un tournage avec des drones ne
s'improvise pas en fait vous allez
marcher le long
côté soleil le long de l'ombre d'accord
moi je vous promets que je sais combien
face au soleil je vous prendre sur le
côté comme ça et je vous dis quand c'est
bon on est énormément d'obstacles on a
des perturbations le vent aussi qu'ils
sont liés au relief et aux différents
arbres donc chaque décollage est très
particulier d'étoilé très différents les
uns des autres
c'est pour ça qu'en fait il ya rien
d'anodin en fait quand on fait décoller
un drone on vérifie tout à l'avant sont
appréciés de 10 minutes là à vérifier
qu'il n'y avait pas une branche qu'on
avait pas vu ou une zone qu'on n'avait
pas identifiées là on est obligé de
scénariser aujourd'hui parce qu'on filme
avec un drone ou pour des raisons de
sécurité il faut que les gens qui sont
là soient des habitués
ce qui seront survolées par un drone ce
qui n'est pas anodin et puis il faut
qu'on cale tout pour savoir exactement
où le drone va passer comment ils
doivent réagir en cas de problème etc
un travail payant pour entreprises qui
s'est lancée dans la prise de vue avec
des drones l'année dernière en plus de
son activité de communication avec ses
différents moyens techniques et de
production
le concept proposé par canopée séduit
les acteurs du territoire
l'entreprise vient de signer plusieurs
contrats avec des acteurs économiques
importants comme le crédit agricole sa
est un petit peu plus long que prévu
mais pas lié à la crise doit quoi que ce
soit mais jusqu'à la météo donc depuis
qu'il fait beau depuis un mois à peu
près bon envol beaucoup entend beaucoup
enfin beaucoup d'image et on se rend
compte qu'on a bien fait de se diriger
dans ce sens là et la façon dont trois
faits semblent fonctionner donc donc
c'est plutôt positif avec la saison
estivale edouard génie espère multiplier
les tournages c'est le moment pour qu'à
nos pays de prendre de la hauteur et
c'est bientôt la fin de notre émission
mais avant de vous quitter je vous
propose de regarder avec moi à l'agenda
la semaine
et cette semaine je vous propose de voir
avec moi deux rendez vous si vous êtes
intéressés par le développement de votre
activité à l'export la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
organise ce lundi 22 juin de 14 heures à
18 heures une rencontre sur le thème de
l'exportation et des opportunités en
amérique latine
c'est une rencontre gratuite renseignez
vous auprès de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles le 25 juin la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines institut la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles et l'association delta ce qui
vous invite à participer à un colloque
intitulé entreprises et territoires
ensemble pour une mobilité durable bilan
est en jeu des plans de déplacement
inter-entreprises c'est un événement
destiné aux entreprises du territoire
mais aussi aux collectivités et aux
partenaires régionaux en matière de
déplacements et de transport le rendez
vous est fixé de 9 heures à midi dans
les locaux de la société et vis à
guyancourt
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de fil et qu il
ne me restait plus qu'à vous souhaiter
une très bonne soirée